the norwegian nobel committee has
decided to award the nobel peace prize
for 2016 to Colombian President Juan
Manuel Santos for his resolute efforts
to bring the country's more than 50 year
long civil war to an end a word that had
costs has cost the life of at the lives
of at least 220,000 Colombians and
displaced close to six million people
the award should also be seen as a
tribute to the Colombian people who
despite great hardships and abuses have
not given up hope of a just peace and to
all the parties who have contributed to
this peace process this tribute is paid
not least to the representatives of the
countless victims of the Civil War
President Santos initiated the
negotiations that culminated in the
peace accord between the Colombian
government and the FARC guerrillas and
he has consistently sought to move the
peace process forward well knowing that
the Accord was controversial he was
instrumental in ensuring that Colombian
voters were able to voice their opinion
concerning the Accord in a referendum
the outcome of the vote was not what
President Santos wanted a narrow
majority of the over 13 million
Colombians who cast their ballots said
no to the Accord this result has created
great uncertainty as to the future of
Colombia there is a real danger that the
peace process will come to a halt and
that civil war will flare up again
this makes it even more important that
the party's headed by president Santos
and fart guerilla leader Rodrigo London
you continue to respect the cease-fire
the fact that the majority of the voters
said no to the peace accord does not
necessarily mean that a peace process is
dead the referendum was not a vote for
or against peace the referendum was the
no side what the no side rejected was
not the desire for peace but a specific
peace agreement the Norwegian Nobel
Committee emphasizes the importance of
the fact that President Santos is now
inviting all parties to participate in a
broad-based national dialogue aimed at
advancing the peace process even those
who opposed the peace accord have
welcomed such a dialogue the nobel
committee hopes that all parties will
take their share of responsibility and
participate constructively in the
upcoming peace talks striking a balance
between the need for national
reconciliation and ensuring justice for
the victims will be a particularly
difficult challenge there are no simple
answers as to how this should be
accomplished an important feature of the
Colombian peace process so far has been
the participation of representatives of
the civil war victims witnessing the
courage and will of the victims
representatives to testify about
atrocities
and to confront the perpetrators from
every side of the conflict has made a
profound impression by awarding this
year's Peace Prize to President Juan
Manuel Santos the norwegian nobel
committee wishes to encourage all those
who are striving to achieve peace
reconciliation and justice in colombia
the President himself has made it clear
that he will continue to work for peace
right up until the very last day in
office the committee hopes that the
Peace Prize will give him strength to
succeed in this demanding task
furthermore it is the committee's hope
that in the years to come the Colombian
people will reap the fruits of the
ongoing peace and reconciliation process
only then will the country be able to
address effectively major challenges
such as poverty social in Rusty's and
drug-related crime the civil war in
Colombia is one of the longest civil
wars in modern times and the sole
remaining armed conflict in the Americas
it is the Norwegian Nobel Committee
sperm belief that president Santos
despite the majority vote in the
referendum has brought the bloody
conflict significantly closer to a
peaceful solution and that much of the
groundwork has been led for both the
verifiable disarmament of the FARC
guerrillas and a historic process of
national fraternity and reconciliation
his endeavors to promote peace thus
fulfilled the criteria and spirit of
alfred nobel's will